[Musique]
mon mari a été hospitalisé lundi
à 17 heures le mardi j'ai eu un appel
d'une proche qui travaille à l'hôpital
et qui me disait qu'il fallait que je me
rapproche des médecins des urgences et
je pense qu'inconsciemment je ne voulais
pas entendre ce qu la lisca les médias
le médecin
je les visite il jeudi après midi le
vendredi le samedi j'avais le sentiment
qu'il allait un peu mieux et mon cas des
caves est hospitalisé qu'il n'avait pas
vu depuis qu'elle joue souhaité le
rencontrer donc je l'encouragé et c'est
lui qui a découvert son père décédé
je pense que ça s'était passé dans
l'heure qui présidait son arrivée dans
ça a été difficile bonus
ya pas eu d'accompagnement il n'y a pas
eu de présentation du core os les gens
parallèlement qui ne sont pas décidés du
coc vide avec cet accompagnement il ya
eu des présentations ce qu'on appelle
les présentations de lokossa moment de
rassemblement avec la famille avant de
mettre en bien referme définitivement le
cercueil mais non ça
il y à un mois magee a donné louvain à
enterrer son mari christian emportés par
le cos vide à la maison tout le monde a
été contaminé son fils sa belle-fille sa
petite fille à l'image de la famille de
maggie c'est toute la martinique qui a
été frappé cet été par une quatrième
vague meurtrière
les gens viennent préparer la to say est
un média la table ils se rencontraient
aussi des membres de la famille se
retrouvent autour de la table dans des
cas comme ça et se remémorer leur ment
et il y aura aussi quand même beaucoup
de difficultés ont pas été accompagné
sur les derniers instants qui ont été
hospitalisés qui ont été ensevelies
comme ça très vite et ce moment de deuil
de recueillement qu'on aille
d'accompagnement connaît jusqu'à la
tombe beaucoup ne l'ont pas vécu et ça
reste quand même un moment flou moments
de doute
[Musique]
je
le chu de fort de france est l'épicentre
de la crise
le docteur chat bartier le professeur
cabié sont encore sous le choc de la
violence de cette quatrième vague on a
commencé à être en grande tension dans
la deuxième quinzaine du mois de juillet
et on a commencé à normaliser la prise
en charge vers le 15 septembre à peu
près pendant ces deux mois on était en
catastrophe quotidienne en temps normal
il ya vingt lits de réanimation
polyvalente et 6 lits de réanimation
chirurgie cardiaque et on les monte
environ 115 détermination au maximum de
capacité et malgré sa passe une histoire
mais après ça ils n'en étaient encore
complètement au dessus pour attribuer un
lit d animation extrêmement rare eh bien
on va appliquer certains critères pour
prioriser le malade qui va le plus en
bénéficier donc c'est à dire qu'on
réfléchisse différemment de d'habitude
on parle plus de critères dans
l'animation on parle du patient qui a le
plus de chance ce s'en sortir
malgré le reflux progressif de la
quatrième vague l'attention hospitalière
reste forte dans le service de
réanimation ce jour là une trentaine de
patients qu'ovide sont intubés
[Musique]
une situation que le sénateur bernard
jomier est venu constater sur le terrain
voilà deux ans que ce médecin de
formation enquête sur la gestion de la
pandémie partout sur le territoire alors
je suis à fort de france c'est vraiment
l'épicentre
évidemment
du traitement de la pandémie en
martinique
on va le chu
c'est
un peu de la capacité du chu à faire
face
dépend la capacité du système de soins
en martinique à faire face
fort de la crise on avait à peu près 200
patients qui étaient dans les services
de médecine et alors qu'ils auraient dû
être en réanimation des personnes sous
canisy d'oxygène en train d'étouffer
dans les services de médecine et une
incapacité à les prendre en charge
correctement donc ça c'est un
traumatisme d'une violence inouïe bien
sûr pour les patients pour leur famille
avec des dessins des épisodes récurrents
de tension avec les avis et bien sûr
pour les soignants qui se trouve
complètement démunis dans cette dans
cette situation
pendant que bernard jomier entend le
témoignage des médecins la situation se
tend à l'extérieur du chu des soignants
manifestent contre l'obligation
vaccinale
[Applaudissements]
celle ci doit entrer en vigueur dans
quelques jours en martinique un mois
après la métropole mais une majorité des
civils salariés de l'hôpital refuse pour
l'instant de se faire vacciner
chantal que fait le gouvernement est
abject un digne d'une république qui se
dit une république de la liberté il ya
une chose qui regonfle mon coeur c'est
de voir comment martinique est debout
comme en mars lié au combat
[Musique]
mobilisons aujourd'hui contre cette
obligation vaccinale aussi contre le
pass sanitaires pour accéder à un
établissement de soins une pression pas
possible qu'ils exerçaient sur les
soignants sur nos collègues notamment
sur les collègues libéraux qui se
sentent isolés et qui vont contraint et
forcé bien souvent vers cette
vaccination obligatoire on nous vend
comme salutaire alors que l'état des
connaissances scientifiques
aujourd'hui ne nous permet pas d'avoir
assez de recul sur les effets
secondaires de cette injection
parmi les agents qui sont là forcément
ya plein de jeunes qui vont se faire
vacciner mais c'est des jeunes qui sont
en lutte depuis plusieurs jours c'est
des jeunes qui sont convaincus qu'il
faut pas moins de la taxe que c'est pas
bon pour le corps que cette violence qui
a réalisé à l'encan que c'est une somme
de viol mais bon là prennent pas ce que
vaut sans doute mieux se retrouver à la
rue mais quand ils ont su que ça comme
une maltraitance comment demain ils
pourront avoir suffisamment d'empathie
le patient qui seront là
[Applaudissements]
il ya beaucoup de ressentiment vis-à-vis
des soignants principalement des
médecins mais mais pas seulement parce
qu'une grande majorité des médecins est
vacciné et finalement on a on a une
cristallisation autour d'eux des
personnes vaccinées d'un côté non
vaccinés de l'autre la vaccination a
quand même a toujours du mal à prendre
en martinique et donc il n'ya pas de
raison pour qu'on n'évolue pas vers une
cinquième vague d'une sixième vague
[Musique]
salut
à l'image des soignants qui rejette
l'obligation vaccinale c'est toute la
campagne de vaccination qui patinent en
martinique faisant redouter une
cinquième vague dans le centre de
vaccination ambulant que bernard jomier
visite à sainte anne dans le sud de
l'île il n'y a pas foule sans la
martinique à seulement 300 nouvelles
personnes qui sont vaccinées par jour
c'est très peu dans un bus de ce type là
ça va être 20 ou 30 personnes dans la
journée ce sera déjà un bon résultat
évidemment il faudrait qu'il y en ait
beaucoup plus parce qu'à ce rythme là
d'une nouvelle vague risque de déferler
sur la martinique avec de nouveaux des
situations très préoccupante pour la
prise en charge des patients une
défiance défiance vis-à-vis de l'état
l'état des sciences de la vie de
l'étincelle parce qu'il ya voilà il ya
un ses rôles à qui a été
un peu remué là depuis quelques années
et c'est aussi sur ce terreau que la
défiance vis-à-vis du vaccin et
[Musique]
si
dans ma commune je ne sens pas il ya une
volonté de faire quelque chose sur la
commune cet espace où je vis social
permettrait là se joue quelque chose
très important pour l'avenir dans la
capacité à vacciner plus rapidement et
veille à l'implication des élus des
relais locaux
les élus locaux justement la sénatrice
de martinique catherine conconne leur
reproche de ne pas assez défendre la
vaccination
aujourd'hui depuis ce matin ils ont fait
dix personnes ça fait beaucoup de moyens
déployés pour 10 personnes alors qu'on
est toujours par à 40 consomme vacciner
on est loin de la moitié donc il faut un
accompagnement des fonds que nous
absolument
conscient que oui nous faut vaccin mais
si bourgi nouveau vaccin
conny des boucles une idée grotesque qui
travaille à un système équilibré banon
vaccin qui a sauvé nous de la forme
grave ducobu vous savez il ya beaucoup
de gens fous qui le créole est plus
simplement timide c'est la langue du
coeur c'est la langue de la proximité
ils moi j'utilise le créole depuis que
je suis en forme a jamais empêché de
parler crier donc j'utilise le créole
parce que lorsqu'on parle à une bonne
personne personnage et en créole on la
pénètre mieux elle comprend mieux et ça
rapproche aussi les gens donc le créole
est aussi un élément qui me c'est aussi
dans beaucoup de circonstances à dire
mais nos mamies faut pas écouter ce
hayon radio
novak cents par action voilà
[Musique]
sur les 34 maires de la martinique
rares sont ceux qui appellent
ouvertement à la vaccination
à saint-pierre dans le nord christian
rafa est une exception
[Musique]
mais pourrait over power oui car juste
avant ok c'est bon
on y va
pyrrhotine pierrotin je vous demande
quelques minutes d'attention c'est votre
mère christian rafa qui vous parle le
virus coronavirus circule activement et
nombreuses de nombreuses familles
pyrrhotine ont été endeuillées méfions
nous de ce virus la cinquième vague nous
menacent je vous rappelle que le centre
de vaccination éphémère de la guinguette
peut vous recevoir les samedis et les
dimanches sans rendez vous je vous
invite vraiment à vous protéger et à
protéger par là même ceux que vous aimez
merci de votre attention on est habitué
ce sont des copains électorale se font
ici sur ce mode là assez souvent on
connaît les points stratégiques où on
peut prendre la parole par exemple ici
sa porte très loin en avant très loin en
arrière donc on va s'arrêter ici
perrotine pierrotin c'est votre mère
christ et rafa qui s'adresse à vous
ensemble luttons contre ce virus en nous
protégeant ça qui nous permettra aussi
de protéger ceux que nous aimons autour
de nous merci de votre attention
et maurice tulle abrita d'oise oboro vos
vaccins
ben ouais ça qui vivait là
bon il était costaud un nom mais on a
perdu quand même c'est triste
on t'attend c'est quand tu veux
on a perdu
quelqu'un de très connu à saint pierre
un athlète il était physiquement il
c'est un sportif 61 ans il est mort la
semaine dernière après quinze jours de
coma et toute la ville était enfin dix
ans il y avait plus de 200 personnes à
l'enterrement et beaucoup de pleurs je
pense que c'est un ami de ce monsieur et
il sait tout le monde apprend beaucoup
de gens ont pris conscience que ce virus
là il est il est impitoyable
tu vas bien oui alors
où est ce que tu en es tu toi je la
vaccination
tu n'y crois pas
tu as déjà pris de dos
d'accord c'est ça que je vous disait il
il est en train de me dire qu'il entend
des trucs il entend d'autres trucs et
qu'on lui l'entre-deux il sait pas quoi
faire
vous avez vu ça à personne par personne
c'est ce que j'explique est là il faut
vraiment aller déminer la tête des gens
individuellement il ya des gens que
j'arrive à confie à convaincre
simplement parce qu'ils nous font
confiance je suis un professionnel de
santé qui a exercé ici pendant 30 ans
donc les gens me connaissent en tant que
tels ils me disent monsieur rafah qu'est
ce que tu penses du vaccin je le redis
je leur dis t'as intérêt à le prendre et
ça suffit ça prend 30 secondes et puis
on a d'autres vous pouvez leur parler
pendant une journée ils vont vous sortir
des faits que qu'ils ont entendu partout
à droite à gauche et à la fin ils vous
disent bon je vais voir j'ai presque
réussi à convaincre ce monsieur qui est
là bas et j'en suis pas mécontent
[Musique]
maman
c'est vrai
[Musique]
la méfiance vis-à-vis du vaccin est
aussi alimentée par les fakes news pour
la sénatrice catherine conconne le
poison de la rumeur a fait beaucoup de
dégâts en martinique
un poison contre lequel elle lutte aux
côtés du maire de saint-pierre christian
rafah
les jo étaient super organisé ça tapait
très fort et quand vous prenez une vague
comme ça vous savez un temps de réaction
il faut trouver une contre réaction qui
soit efficace je me rappelle de ce fait
qui est arrivé nous professionnels de
santé ou soignants vous conseillons bien
sûr la médecine traditionnelle à base de
plantes de boire de l'eau purifiée de
ceux de se mettre au soleil 35 30
minutes par jour pour éviter de manger
des fruits et légumes et ça et ne
surtout pas se faire vacciner donc on se
déguise en professionnels de santé pour
que ça puisse être encore plus efficace
c'est c'est pernicieux et dû démonter ça
parce que ça circulait sur mon roi de sa
politique vecteur de communication
puissant c'est pas la télé c'est pas
leur argent je suis convaincu que si le
réseau watts tout à fait voilà je note
donc il suffit de mai il fera sur axa de
mettre une photo et ça fait le tour de
l'île en quelques heures et
pour contrer l'effet news catherine
conconne a été la première élue a
annoncé publiquement qu'elle se faisait
vacciner
j'étais
la première publiquement à passer dans
les médias et à dire que je mettais pacs
signés il ya des gens qui ont trouvé ça
très bien en me disant c'est bien de
montrer l'exemple alors il y avait ceux
des antilles vax qui ont qui m'ont même
dit que c'était du faux vaccins que en
fait c'est une image mais que j'étais
pas vacciner c'est du sérum
physiologique comme avait injecté enfin
bref et du truc complètement hallucinant
j'ai eu des menaces
après des
manifestations dans fort de france qui
ont mal tourné il ya eu un incendie d'un
vaccinodromes j'ai fait un communiqué de
presse où je déplorais cette ambiance
l'incendié du vaccinodromes les émeutes
qui s'était passé les magasins qui a été
cassé à fort de france j'ai des menaces
de mort et des graffitis dans
fort-de-france jusqu'à présent en créole
qui m'insultent et où
quand je dis j'ai fait toutes les
guerres donc de plus
[Rires]
on n'est pas découragé loin de là
puisque on a appris hier et avant-hier
nous avons passé la barre symbolique des
40 % de martinique est vaccinée ça
laisse de l'espoir je pense que les
choses se débloquent petit à petit les
jambons ils ont réussi à avoir des
informations il donc ça avance on va pas
se décourager
on continue son combat est on est on est
on est convaincu qu'on va le gagner
christian rafa poursuit son combat
mais les opposants au vaccin ne désarme
pas non plus
[Musique]
à
l'appel des syndicats
les manifestations contre l'obligation
vaccinale des soignants et le passé
annie terre sont quotidiennes
le député indépendantiste jean-philippe
ni l'or est l'un des leaders du midi
les problèmes économiques les problèmes
sociaux
les contentieux historique avec la
parole de l'état
on peut comprendre que
leur cas ne va pas céder aussi
facilement et qui va rentrer dans les
millions il va entrer en résistance
personnellement
j'ai bien peur du vaccin de bénéfice
risque du vaccin par toutes les couches
de la population et toutes les cibles
n'étant pas vacciné je ne vais pas
appeler
décemment mes compatriotes à se faire
vacciner
parole d'un peuple
ses adversaires lui reprochent de faire
de la politique sur le dos de la crise
sanitaire jean philippe miller sont
défend et plaide pour la liberté
vaccinale
et nous est cher parce qu'elle est on
arrivé
à notre liberté est vécue de manière
beaucoup plus passionnel
dans beaucoup de pays d'outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
servez le
président arménien pellepoix catalan et
sakic a frappé mois le plus ses manières
nous qu'il a new kick à gré c'est quand
injustice tant la cayolle est obligé lui
subi en moyenne on va rester faut
70 % d'un peuple ne peut pas se tromper
donc il ya des choses à entendre il ya
des choses à leur dire aussi
certainement mais il faut user d'une
autre forme de pédagogie c'est pas nous
accusons début du vaudou is d'être
adorateurs de la vierge marie d'être des
12h de rome ce n'est pas à partir de 16
7 ce socle idéologique la province
parvenir à nous convaincre nous avons
subi suffisamment de coercition dans ce
pays et la violence malheureusement va
après la violence et la violence qui va
venir du kop jeu le courage de dire
qu'elle sera légitime
pour essayer de faire retomber la
pression le préfet de la martinique a
fait appel à des personnalités locales
après un brillant sociologue dignité
ces personnalités issues de la société
civile sont réunis dans un comité
citoyen de transparence elles doivent
porter auprès de la population une
parole indépendante de celle de l'état
sur la crise sanitaire il ya eu aussi
une forme de protection contre c'est pas
seulement contre l'état mais contre
l'autorité entre le déni il ya eu aussi
ce phénomène là donc ça demande si cette
équipe ne mérite ni de retiers un peu on
nourrit un peu plus la discussion et si
on peut limiter
mon hélas beaucoup
le premier vaccin dépasse largement le
vaccin
c'est une société qui ne va pas très
bien qui a beaucoup de ressentiment dina
métropole notamment et à l'occasion de
cette question du vaccin et l'obligation
vaccinale
ce sont tous ces ressentiments qui
ressorte et qui explose avec une
instrumentalisation délibérée de
certains ça a été dit aussi une serait
mentalisation politiques notamment et
puis une masse de personnes beaucoup de
personnes qui se posent des questions et
qui sont prises entre tous ces discours
et il faut démêler tous ses fils pour
arriver à faire progresser la protection
collective
[Musique]
bernard jomier rentrer à paris pour
alerter le gouvernement sur la situation
en martinique
pour l'écrivain andré lucrèce membres du
comité citoyen de transparence cette
crise est un révélateur
il ya un ouvrage que j'ai est cuit il ya
une vingtaine d'années
c'est un ouvrage qui s'intitule
souffrance et jouissance aux antilles
j'ai repris un certain nombre de thèses
de ce livre parce que il dit finalement
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
une phrase qui est qui est extrêmement
importante
je dis ceci dans ce livre une réflexion
de tous karam qui est un poète indien
dit ceci elle a attiré d'ailleurs mon
attention
je suis venu de loin
j'ai beaucoup souffert j'ai souffert
même démo effrayant
et j'ignore ce que me réserve au passé
et j'ai l'impression que les
martiniquais sont précisément dans cet
esprit là il voit le futur à travers
leur passé et en particulier
par rapport au passé douloureux
passé douloureux ça veut dire en premier
de l'esclavagé mines entendu mais pas
seulement ça veut dire aussi le scandale
du chlordécone ça veut dire aussi la
grande grève qui a eu en 2009 et vous
voyez tous ces éléments-là remonte à la
surface
par rapport
je dirais aux autorités
répandu sur les bananeraies aux antilles
le chlordécone est un pesticide à
l'origine de cancers et à polluer les
sols et les rivières
sa dangerosité a longtemps été niée par
les autorités sanitaires
un scandale qui explique en partie la
méfiance des martiniquais envers les
consignes de l'état
mais pour andré lucrèce cette méfiance a
une origine plus ancien encore nous
sommes dans une société qui a connu les
ravages et donc
le corps de l'esclave si vous voulez
il est le reflet de toute une série date
et en particulier
d'actes de souffrance et donc il n'ya si
vous voulez
née de cette histoire une sorte ndt
unité du corps
le martiniquais chien à l'intégrité de
son corps et donc de ce point de vue de
menthe et nick est donc
très attentif à tout ce qui touche à son
corps et en particulier aux piqûres
les crises sont toujours révélatrices de
quelque chose de sous jacents j'ai pensé
donc au projet d'un livre sur cette
situation qui est au fond si tu voulais
le traitement d'une crise les gens sont
très fair use donc de ce genre
d'explications parce qu'ils veulent
savoir ils veulent comprendre quelle est
la trajectoire de notre société
[Musique]